remember in 2016 and 2017 cnn was doing
a bunch of individual town halls with
individual people that wasn't because
they cared they were simply testing to
see how much money they would get in ad
revenue if any of them were popular they
would then put them in the debate stage
it was about popularity it wasn't about
whether they care or not popularity
matters people say larry how come we
didn't get in the polls because you have
to buy the polls to get in the polls
it's not about it's about cash right so
if i want to be in a poll
it's not just because i'm the official
candidate i found this out the hard way
i have to buy the poll a poll costs
about forty thousand dollars if i'm
raising millions i'll buy some polls
every week i'll buy a poll every month
i'll buy a poll when i'm raising half a
million dollars over my entire campaign
am i gonna be able to take ten percent
of that and throw it a poll and maybe
come in poorly probably not it's not a
not a responsible use of my campaign
funds right so you have to buy a poll
well larry why aren't you in the press
why aren't you in the press well because
you have to buy ads to be in the press
if you buy ads they then cover you if
you don't buy ads they don't cover you
it's that simple it's all pay to play